مساء الخير،
القرن السابع ميلادي،
سوف يشهد ميلاد الدين التوحيدي الثالث،
وهو الإسلام
في شبه جزيرة العرب.
هذه المنطقة من العالم
لم تكن في ظلمات الجاهلية
كما صورتها لنا كتب التراث الإسلامي،
شبه جزيرة العرب تقع في مفترق بؤرة حضارية
بين بلاد فارس وبلاد الرافدين وبلاد الشام ومصر،
وكانت ارض جدل لاهوتي،
أطرافه،
اليهود الذين استقرّوا أساسا في يثرب،
وفرقا نصرانية مضادة لعقيدة التثليث،
فرّت من بطش الكنيسة الرسمية المسيحية،
ومن اهمها،
النسطورية،
والآريوسية،
والابيونية،
وكذلك وجود  تيار توحيدي محلّي
يسمّى اتباعه بالحنفاء،
من أهم رموزه،
قس بن ساعدة الإيادي،
وزيد بن عمرو بن نُفيل القرشي،
وأمية ابن أبي الصلت الثقفي،
وكان هؤلاء يقولون انهم على ملّة ابراهيم،
ويرفضون عبادة اصنام القرشيين،
ويختتنون،
ويحجون للبيت،
وهم ينحدرون من عائلات مرموقة في القبائل العربية،
وعرف عنهم انهم أصحاب علم وحكمة.
الرسول اعتبرهم على ملة إبراهيم،
وعدّ مصيرهم الجنة،
رغم انهم لم يعتنقوا الإسلام.
اليهود والنصارى والحنفاء
سوف يكونون الروافد الروحية الأساسية
لعقيدة التوحيد الإسلامية.
الإسلام سوف يمنح كذك العرب
اول كتاب بلسانهم وهو القرآن،
نص سوف يشهد ثلاث لحظات هامّة،
لحظة النزول والتي ستدوم حوالي ثلاثة وعشرين عاما،
ثم لحظة الجمع والتوحيد في مصحف واحد
في عهد الخليفة عثمان بن عفان،
بعد أن تفرّق في عدة مصاحف،
ظهرت فيها عدة اختلافات،
احرقت كلها،
وهي في تقديري لحظة توحيدية
تعادل في أهميتها لحظة مجمع نيقية بالنسبة للديانة المسيحية،
اما اللحظة الثالثة الهامة
فهي لحظة الصراع بين المعتزلة و الحنابلة
حول حدوث أو قدم القرآن
في بداية القرن الثالث للهجرة.
الحنابلة قالوا ان القرآن صفة لذات الله،
وبما ان ذات الله قديمة فإن صفاتها قديمة،
إذن القرآن قديم.
اما المعتزلة،
فيعتبرون ان القرآن من صفات الفعل الالاهي
وليس من صفات ذات الله،
إذن فهو حادث لأن الفعل الالاهي حادث،
مثل فعلي خلق الإنسان أو خلق الكون.
القرآن عند المعتزلة لم يكن ثم كان،
وعند الحنابلة هو قديم
ووجد منذ الأزل في اللوح المحفوظ.
موقف الحنابلة، لا يستقيم منطقيا،
فكيف
للنص،
الذي من حيث المبنى نزل على سبعة احرف
حسب لهجات القبائل العربية،
وله قراءات متعددة ومختلفة،
ومن حيث المعنى
يحتوي على المحكم و المتشابه
ويخضع لمبدأ الناسخ والمنسوخ
ويحتمل عدة تأويلات
كان من نتائجها
ظهور المذاهب والفرق المختلفة
أن يكون واحدا ومطلقا وقديما؟
ثم الإشكال الثاني،
الذي طرحه اهل الاعتزال،
وهو اذا كان الله قديم
والقرآن قديم
فسوف نكون ازاء قديمين
وهذا يمس من عقيدة وحدانية الله.
الخليفة العباسي المتوكل سوف ينتصر للحنابلة،
وسوف تتحول محنة القرآن إلى محنة المعتزلة
الذين تم حرق مؤلفاتهم على أيدي الحنابلة،
ولم يصلنا منها سوى القليل،
من اهمها
كتابات القاضي عبد الجبار
التي حفظها الزيديون في اليمن.
الحنابلة وورثتهم في الفقه الإسلامي،
سوف يصادرون النص القرآني،
ويُسكنونه في السماء
بعيدا عن مشاغل الناس الذين نزل لأجلهم.
هذا النص المؤسس للحضارة العربية الإسلامية،
سوف نعيد اكتشافه في العصر الحديث
من خلال قراأت المستشرقين له،
من كتاب "تاريخ القرآن"،
للمستسرق الألماني تيودور نولدكِه،
الذي صدر سنة 1860،
وصولا إلى كتاب قراءة آرامية  سريانية للقرآن،
ﻟﻜﺮﻳﺴﺘﻮﻑ ﻟﻜﺴﻨﺒﺮﺝ
الذي صدر سنة 2007،
وقائمة كتب المستشرقين،
التي درست القرآن، بين الكتابين
طويلة وطويلة جدا.
لحسن الحظ،
مؤخرا ظهر عدة كتاب و مفكرين عرب ومسلمين
تجرؤوا على الشروع في استرداد النص القرآني،
وتحريره من سجن العقل اللاهوتي السلفي
لدراسته وفق المناهج العلمية الحديثة،
وفي هذا الإطار تأتي قراءة المفكر المصري عبد الجواد ياسين
للتشريع داخل النص القرآني.
عبد الجواد ياسين يعتبر ان التشريع في النص القرآنى
هو نتاج لواقع اجتماعي معين،
وهو لحظة الوحي الأولى؛
أي واقع مكة والمدينة في القرن السابع الميلادي.
والأصل الإجتماعي لهذا التشريع،
يجعله جزأ لا يتجزأ من التدين وليس من الدين.
يعطي عبد الجواد ياسين في كتابه
أمثلة من القوانين التشريعية في النص القرآنى
وكيف انها لم تخرج عن نطاق العرف السائد
في شبه جزيرة العرب.
في أحكام الزواج والأسرة ؛
مثلا
وافقت أحكام الزواج في القرآن
أحكام الزواج عند العرب قبل الإسلام،
فقد عرفت العرب قبل الإسلام
سلطة الولي في عقد الزواج،
وعرفت كذلك المهر كركن ضروري في عقد الزواج،
يفرّق بين الزواج والمسافحة،
وعرف العرب كذلك تعدد الزوجات،
وفي المحارم من النساء
وافق التشريع القرآني أعراف القبائل العربية،
بإستثناء الزواج بزوجة الأب والجمع بين الأختين.
كذلك مبدأ التكافؤ بين الزوجين من جهة المكانة الاجتماعية
كشرط صحة في عقد الزواج،
هو عرف وجد عند العرب قبل الإسلام،
فقيل:
العرب أكفّاء العرب.
في الجماع كذلك،
اعتبر النص القرآني حيض المرأة أذى،
وأمر الرجال باعتزال النساء في المحيض،
وهو عرف جاهلي معروف،
في الطلاق كذلك،
تبنى القرآن نظام الطلاق الشائع في قريش
وبعض القبائل العربية الأخرى،
وهو العرف الذي يجعل العصمة اساسا في يد الرجل،
ويحصر عدد مرات الطلاق في ثلاث،
يصير بعدها الطلاق بائنا بينونة كبرى
لا تنقضي الا بزواج المرأة من رجل اخر ثم طلاقها منه.
لكن القرآن أدخل تعديلا في أمر الطلاق،
فأمر المطلقات ان يتربصن بانفسهن ثلاثة قروء،
في حين كانت المطلقة قبل الإسلام تتزوج بمجرّد طلاقها من دون عدة.
اما في حالة وفاة الزوج،
فقد أقر الإسلام نفس عرف الجاهلية،
حيث يجعل المرأة تحدّ على زوجها المتوفى لمدة سنة كاملة.
في تشريع ميراث البنت،
مثلا
وقاعدة للذكر مثل حظ الأنثيين،
يقول عبد الجواد ياسين؛
يذكر ابن حبيب في كتابه المُحبَّر،
ان أوّل من جعل للبنات نصيبا من الإرث من الجاهليين
هو ذو المجاسد اليشكري،
وهو من الحنفاء،
ورّث ماله في الجاهلية،
فجعل للذكر مثل حظ الأنثيين،
فوافق حكمه حكم الإسلام.
إذن
القرآن في معالجته لمسائل الزواج والأسرة
كان يترجم الثقافة العامة في شبه جزيرة العرب قبل الإسلام.
كذلك تشريعات القتال،
في النص القرآنى
تعود جذورها في العرف السائد في الحرب قبل الإسلام.
حيث كانت ظروف الحياة القاسية في بيئة صحراوية قاحلة
هي السبب الرئيسي للغارات والحروب بين القبائل،
وكانت الغنائم احد المصادر الأساسية للعيش.
بعد هجرة الرسول من مكة إلى المدينة
وبالتحول من وضعية الاستضعاف والصبر على الأذى،
إلى وضعية مواجهة الخصوم عسكريا،
سوف يتغير خطاب النص القرآني،
يميز عبد الجواد ياسين بين السكينة الإيمانية في القرآن المكي
وبين الجيشان الإجتماعي والسياسي في القرآن المدني.
الخطاب القرآني المدني سوف يحول عرف الغزو القبلي إلى جهاد،
الذي سيتحول في الفقه إلى فريضة دينية مؤبدة،
يتم بمقتضاه تقسيم العالم إلى قسمين،
دار الإسلام ودار الحرب.
وكما أقرت أعراف الجاهلية
بحق القاتل في الاستيلاء على سلب قتيله
كذلك فقه القتال الإسلامي
سوف يدرج أحكام السلب ضمن أبواب الغنيمة.
وفي تقسيمه للغنائم،
اعتمد النص القرآني على العرف السائد،
حيث كان لرؤساء القبائل الأقوياء قبل الإسلام
الحق في الحصول على ربع غنائم الجيش،
ويسمى هذا النصيب بالمرباع،
النص القرآني سوف يجعله خمسا،
ويكون من نصيب الرسول؛
" وَاعْلَمُوا أَنَّمَا غَنِمْتُم مِّن شَيْءٍ فَأَنَّ لِلَّهِ خُمُسَهُ وَلِلرَّسُولِ
وَلِذِي الْقُرْبَىٰ وَالْيَتَامَىٰ وَالْمَسَاكِينِ وَابْنِ السَّبِيلِ".
الأنفال 41.
إذن المرباع الجاهلي هو أصل الخمس الإسلامي.
كذلك في ما يخص التشريع الجنائي؛
عقوبة قطع اليد كحد للسرقة،
كانت عقوبة معروفة عند العرب قبل الإسلام
وخاصة عند قريش.
وينسبها البعض إلى عبد المطلب جد الرسول،
وينسبها آخرون إلى الوليد بن المغيرة.
كما أقرّ النص القرآني في تشريعاته القصاص،
وهو كذلك عرف جاهلي،
واستوعب النص القرآنى عرف التكافؤ في الدماء،
كشرط من شروط العصمة،
يترتب على تخلفه عدم استحقاق القصاص،
وهو تشريع يكشف كما قال عبد الجواد ياسين
عن قسوة منافية للروح الإنسانية للدين.
ورد في النص القرآني؛
"يَا أَيُّهَا الَّذِينَ آمَنُوا كُتِبَ عَلَيْكُمُ الْقِصَاصُ فِي الْقَتْلَى الْحُرُّ بِالْحُرِّ وَالْعَبْدُ بِالْعَبْدِ وَالْأُنثَىٰ بِالْأُنثَىٰ"
البقرة 178.
الإمام الشافعي في كتابه الأم
يؤكد أن دم الكافر لا يكافىء دم المؤمن،
ودم العبد لا يكافىء دم الحر.
التأويل الفقهي هنا ينحاز الى اجتماعيات الرق
على حساب الروح الأخلاقية وجوهر الدين.
لكن تجدر الإشارة،
انه داخل الفقه الإسلامي وجد فريق من العلماء والفقهاء
انتصر الي مبدأ المساواة في حرمة الدم،
تزعمه الإمام ابو حنيفة،
والذي أقر ان الحر يقتل بالعبد والمسلم يقتل بالذمي.
الديّة كذلك،
كعقوبة بديلة عن القصاص
هي عرف استعاره النص القرآني من أعراف العرب قبل الإسلام.
يشير عبد الجواد ياسين في كتابه الدين والتديّن
إلى ملاحظة على غاية من الأهمية
لإثبات نسبية التشريعات في الديانات التوحيدية الثلاث،
وانها جزء من التدين وليست من جوهر الدين
وهي أن الديانات الثلاثة لم تحرّم العبودية
بل اقرتها وبررتها كنظام اجتماعي
ولم تستوعب التناقض الصارخ بين الأخلاق الكلية الإنسانية والعبودية.
اذن الجزء التشريعي في النص القرآني
وخاصة المدني منه
حسب عبد الجواد ياسين
هو جزء من التدين وليس جزأ من الدين،
هو جزء من التاريخ وليس جزءا من المتاتاريخ.
النص القرآني،
هو الابن الشرعي لبيئته
نزل بلسان عربي
ليتحدّى العرب في أرقى ما أنتجته ثقافتهم الشفاهية وهو الشعر،
يتحدث إبن رشيق القيرواني
عن مكانة الشعر عند العرب قبل الإسلام
فيقول":
"كانت القبيلة من العرب إذا نبغ فيها شاعر أتت القبائل فهنأتها"،
هذا النص القرآني لو نزل في القرن السابع في أثينا مثلا
عوض عن مكة
لكان بلسان يوناني
وربما كان نصا فلسفيا
لان الفلسفة أرقى أشكال التفكير عند اليونان
ولتحدث عن سقراط عوض لقمان الحكيم.
عبد الجواد ياسين يعتبر ان العقل الللاهوتي يخطئ
عندما يلحق الدين بالتدين
و لكن العقل الإجتماعي كذلك يرتكب نفس الخطأ
عندما يلحق الدين بالتدين،
فالعقل الأول سوف يواجه قانون التطور
والعقل الثاني سوف يواجه سؤال الإيمان.
الإنسان حيوان متديّن،
والتدين ظهر قبل ظهور الإنسان العاقل.
إنسان النياندرتال البدائي الذي عاش قبل 350 الف سنة،
كان  يدفن موتاه،
وهو أول شكل من أشكال التدين.
إذن الإنسان في وحدته الأنطولوجية داخل هذا الكون الفسيح
وخاصة امام امتحان الموت ،
يحتاج إلى المقدس الديني،
نبوءة فريدريك نيتشه حول موت الاله لم تتحقق،
والتديّن عاد من جديد وبقوة إلى الفضاء العام،
الفيلسوف الألماني يورغن هابرماس،
احد رموز الجيل الثاني لمدرسة فرانكفورت
في كتابه "بين النزعة الطبيعية والدين"،
يدعو إلى إعادة ترسيم حدود الفضاء العام كما سطّرتها الحداثة
لبناء فضاء عام جديد، ما بعد علماني،
يتعايش فيه المؤمن والملحد والعلمانى بشكل متساو.
ما يمكن استخلاصه من كتاب عبد الجواد ياسين،
أن تضخم التدين ادى إلى تضخم الدين
وجعله في تناقض مع نواميس الإجتماع البشري،
وانه ليس الإقرار بتاريخية النص الديني هو الخطر على المقدّس
بل استبعاد هذه التاريخية هو الخطر على المقدس
لأنه سوف يجعله في تصادم حاد مع قانون التطور.
وكما قال بن رشد:
"الله لايمكن أن يعطينا عقولا ويعطينا شرائع مخالفة لها"
شكرا جزيلا على المتابعة،
أدعوكم للإطلاع على كتاب الدين والتدين لعبد الجواد ياسين،
والى اللقاء في حلقة قادمة
على قناة أنا أفكر إذن أنا موجود...